this is the level of gaslighting and I
hate that word but but it is but I will
use it when it suits my purposes and I
will say that this is a level of
gaslighting that is almost impressive
the news now has to tell you that the
your eyes and ears are you're seeing the
words and they're on the paper but they
have to then tell you that none of the
words actually are any indication of
what the words are supposed to mean this
slander has to
stop and I thank God that
NBC has the guts to come out and say hey
just CA the
president was mentioned 50
times in the
deposition of a victim of a human
trafficker just because he might have
taken said human traffickers plane 25
times or whatever just because the human
trafficker uh best friend jislain
Maxwell was at the president's
daughter's
wedding there is no wrongdoing none of
this
suggests any
wrongdoing by the president it's very
important that
NBC and and all the other news networks
that we know and trust come out and
first and
foremost defend the honor of the man
who's mentioned 50 times in the human
trafficking uh
docks it's very important who will do it
if not
NBC Chris Matthews who used to host hard
ball until I don't even know what
happened I don't know why they threw him
him out I don't think he even did
anything I think he I don't know what he
did I think he made some inappropriate
comment to a woman in an elevator
whatever Chris Matthews his reaction to
the epine thing was like well all of
these politicians they're just they're
broke and they need rides around the
country so some of them end up in these
planes and Rich guys offer to fly them
around yeah this is
uh yeah Chris Matthews
came out and said like uh Hey guys the
clintons can't afford to Charter their
own plane yet they yet I can somehow I
can Charter a private plane if I want to
go perform at s Splitters in Tampa but
the Bill and Hillary
Clinton somehow can't afford a chartered
uh plane so they have to take the
charity of uh Jeffrey
Epstein uh Chris Matthews goes to get
around for their professional and
political
reasons they've become friends with the
wrong freaking people and these people
are frightening and they want something
they want The Prestige of hanging around
a politician so that was uh Chris
Matthews again somebody who works at NBC
that was his
way of understanding it is that it's a
big '90s movie mixup
where you end up on a plane with a human
trafficker at a at an island where
they're having sex org with children
it's a big mixup you weren't supposed to
be there you just needed a ride it was
Planes Trains and Automobiles starring
the ex-president of the United States
and a bunch of
15-year-olds that's what it was and
anyone who thinks it's anything else
you're nut you're crazy
because none of this suggests any
wrongdoing not one not any of it none of
it none of it this is the level of
gaslighting and I hate that word but but
it is but I will use it when it suits my
purposes and I will say that this is a
level of gaslighting that is almost
impressive the news now has to tell you
that the your eyes and ears are you're
seeing the words and they're on the
paper but they have to then tell you
that none of the words actually are any
indication of what the words are
supposed to mean like for example it
would be like me handing you a menu and
then walking over to your table a few
minutes later and going none of this is
food and you go well I don't understand
you go well it's just words on a paper
none of it suggests we have any of the
food you go wait but it's a menu saying
you've got a steak and mashed potatoes
yeah but have you seen any of it well no
I haven't walked back into the kitchen
well then doesn't suggest that we have
it that's what they're saying I mean
this is insane these are the legal
documents these are legal documents this
isn't uh something people made up this
isn't like something people uh uh came
up with on X to be cute these are
genuine legal documents released through
the media you know what I mean they're
not only being hand it's not like the
Twitter files they're not being handed
exclusively to a small group of
journalists these are a a wide
ranging uh institutions are publishing
these uh the veracity is not in question
these are real documents and how many
times find out how many times Clinton's
mentioned I believe it's 50 yeah I think
it's like 56 I quot up yeah it's I
believe it's a 50 to 60 times that the
president of the United States the ex
president of the United
States the ex CIA director uh ahud
Barack the ex- prime minister of Israel
all of these people were mentioned in
the documents but the
media is now coming out and going but by
the way none of them this doesn't
suggest that they did anything
wrong this just uh you know it's just
something that happens I just want to
reiterate to
the who watched this network many of you
were old you got pills falling out of
your mouth you're drooling you're
basically dead what we want to let you
know for the 19th time we're coming in
hot none of this means that anyone did
anything wrong these are just names on a
piece of paper like your name could be
on it or your friend's name could be on
it no one did anything no one did
nothing here this is separate there's
Jeffrey Epstein the human trafficker and
then there's this thing that we got
which is a whole another thing that's
the way the media is handling this this
is different